this review is one of many new videos on
the stouts are critically awesome a DVDs
are still available at the awesome store
calm
[Music]
[Applause]
hello mrs. critic guy remember it so you
don't have to every once in awhile and
astounding internet achievement comes
along that was not done by me what
they're mostly done by me this one
looked at by me
[Music]
the reveals go on signal to try out that
return of yours true after six months of
retirement which internet time is like
10 years this video came out announcing
that your one and only critic was coming
back
it was both poetic daring and not the
least bit pretentious whatsoever
[Music]
not really they've not treated it at all
it perfectly summed up the majesty and
wonder of a man's Queens that a piece of
plastic with a superhero logo on it the
internet exploded fans rejoice and yes
even a few tears were shed mostly to
those who missed demo reel we apologize
to both of you so let's see what changed
the course of all mankind or just got a
trending credit on Twitter which is
difficult this is the review must go on
it opens with everyone's favorite not
replacement Donnie duprey getting
himself some coffee only to find it
suddenly transformed into water ah also
at the Starbucks coffee
confused by this he stares at his water
which according to many viewers is what
most people would like to do rather than
watching demo reel no one does that
anymore never never really yeah is it me
or is the water looking a little um
phallic microphone II know I mean it
must be something trying to communicate
with him that looks like a bring Twinkie
it's tizen volume and get it but he
snaps back to kind of reality as Tacoma
and Rebecca talk about their next film
of Carmen Sandiego movie Carmen Sandiego
has stolen a time machine and she's
going back to history selling all of
history's greatest scores killing Hitler
letting crazy horse win hey as long as
there's a role for acapella does that
too kind of sounds cool but things get
stranger when Rebecca suddenly
disappears followed by Quinn Gwen
gave me this warm baby Bailey is its
yoo-hoo hey come on ages between five
the mentally retarded love you who I
searched the whole internet public
records everything there is no Quinn
well of course not you what some demo
real imagine anyone would want
disappeared I was in that but once
Tacoma vanishes - Donnie starts to panic
look the letter Fox sent to Brian singer
after x-men three Donnie tries
approaching Carl but he doesn't seem to
be himself either
[Music]
yeah still looks more realistic than
tragic world a white light appears and
suddenly were transported to the retina
burning colors of the writers house he
stuck on what he wants to write next
so he takes out the garbage I'm sure
there was a very important reason to
show that baby just demonstrated how
Chester a bum relocates my dad is
perforated move I've ever had in my life
what if I suddenly tonight when he's
still not able to write he gets a knock
on the door from the mailman this calls
for a pointless and rainy style editing
Ruby but he finds the movie he got in
the mail it's not the one he was hoping
for
I ordered the original Auto not the odd
life of Timothy green ah nothing like
that classic stalker can to make you
feel like you're watching something you
probably shouldn't which I guess some
critics would argue is very appropriate
but he makes the mistake every foolishly
optimistic Jennifer Garner fan makes he
puts it on and watches it what follows
is something you see very rarely out of
him all right
No before you grow your tomato child
didn't you think like an orphanage hello
you you could go to an orphanage I
people I think people at all you do know
that we're not supposed to know that you
know there's a camera watching you right
but he literally becomes afraid of his
own shadow and it's inspired to give a
call to his friend Lois I've got a bit
of a question for you shoot do you think
it did the right thing and think
goodness knows our critic well that just
me as my near if you think you only have
enough for once in a while just keep it
once in a while and go out on top hey
look he made himself a robotic chicken
finger thanks man
oh hey uh poyo and harvey say hi to luis
buddy' are you convinced that the
characters from your show are real
people of course not
that's arranged it's just boy on Harvey
that are real okay really is it any
crazier than you seeing your imaginary
characters and talking when nobody's
around we return to the thrilling
continuation of guy staring a computer
screen when he slowly gets the urge to
watch some of his greatest hits only to
find his greatest head start watching
him what am I supposed to go back to
anyway clothing means of running jokes
even always about memes and running
jokes Wow a guy arguing with his
computer screen when clearly no one's
listening
this must be what every forum everywhere
is like every single time you thought
you were done with it you came up with
something better when you had time to
think time to focus time to put that
extra effort in it is very telling that
the time his performance feels the most
honest is when he's praising himself and
why don't you just make me go away see I
told you I can't get rid of me she says
he's following him all over online
without quitting
he's like a facebook gasps he turns off
the computer to remember the glory days
of egos past
[Music]
Christ he's I kind of sing a song is he
I dreamed a dream too bitch and Warren
this calls for some more Sam Raimi fell
edit okay Benson wait a minute what am I
talking about that wasn't Sam Raimi
because that was Shana the dead big
difference he then calls another friend
for advice Lindsay does are you chewing
on something tranquilizers
I've taken enough to kill a baby right
now sorry wow what pharmacy can I go to
to get that I have a very stressed out
horse
should I bring back the nostalgia critic
the critic had a great run but now it's
time to branch out and do new things but
when Z doesn't want to take a chance so
she tells her personnel assassin that
was so much funnier on paper to take
care of the situation
this has been a New York moment New York
monkey New York
you
[Music]
but she confuses his brother for him
yeah I guess all us white people do look
alike just don't go doing the
self-critic anymore there did I just get
trolled by samus from inside out this
affects our star little as he falls
asleep at his kitchen table as most
people do yeah bring it back bring it
back ah pee-wee Herman
what are you doing here it's a dream
dreams your life BAE come on let's go
ride Mark Wahlberg fake penis from 49 oh
boy he's gonna add some questions when
he wakes up you know it's not like we
didn't wonder about this guy already
but his secrets about his well-kept as
Bill Cosby's grocery list he calls up
one last friend to get some advice hello
hey Brad I'm having a debate of whether
or not to bring the nostalgia critic
back oh I don't care well I see a review
of his will be coming up the past seems
to be getting closer though with his
whip and being pushed noting the back
here I didn't want to try new idea
definitely want to do okay as he only
goes who want this place I was just
trying to get you to talk to yourself a
little less but now I see it was
actually pretty counterproductive that's
very stupid okay
word of advice never look in the mirror
let alone open a mirror in something
establishing a creepy tone because it
will inspire something shun worthy any -
something's not shown worthy I'll tell
you what if you answer this honestly
I'll go away forever
do you want to do this again do you have
that same passion you had before she
says he's concerned whether or not to do
an internet show now they could deal
with the fucking devil do you know of
but you know who finally takes him the
forum and they discuss the rules
regarding his return reviews every two
weeks wait we still want these jokes to
still be fresh and funny I need more
time on the
that's going to be two weeks if I have
to hear that time you took one more time
the blood of somebody bald will spill
no more cut-off dates I want to review
whatever I want whenever I want
you're the nostalgia critic it's in your
name we'll give you anything currently
in theaters that one you definitely
don't want to break or dozens of OCD
years will flip their shit and go and
say no although the rule about never
doing another nostalgia critic that
one's okay to break some worlds are more
equal than others this has to be the
first review why I think the real
question is why don't you know this is
the movie that brought you back
basically to the terms and he finally
starts writing his ending his beautiful
well composed totally cop-out ending who
are you what are you I am the creator in
the true winchell person who are now is
the direct result of the choice takoma
you were here to a choice you made for
the sake of the plot plot yes tell me
more Chris Tucker style dance life who
sacrificed yourself to the plot hole
bringing order to chaos your mind
couldn't end the paradox of it all in
martyrdom you know it's a little hard to
make it sound like this was the
intention the whole time when you
literally showed us for 20 minutes this
was not the intention all time he's
shown that he is in fact the nostalgia
critic and that his whole demo reel
experience was the plotholes version of
some sort of purgatory because it
watched as showing us anything it's that
kind of ending goes over especially well
you son of a bitch
do you have any idea how much this shit
star me do you have any ideas I don't
like to go through here oh the tonnopro
maker
I'm a movie but nobody like I tried
telling everybody like good intentions
but no one ever listened to me I lost my
horse I nearly drowned I almost died
trying to fight the nothing but perhaps
now you're a little wiser
you can still criticize all you want but
deep down inside you always know what
it's like to be on the other side
perhaps it'll lead to editorial that
seems surprisingly more understanding
than many of your other videos but if
you look at the inconsistencies of the
character in the past
it still kind of makes sense I'd like
the Zola timeline and if you start with
a Link to the Past and then move on to
about Walters that's portal ACS destiny
that's an order so his former co-stars
seem bizarrely okay with fading away
into nothingness as Donnie walks through
the portal and arrives at the nostalgia
critic in his office huh that was nice
of reality to leave his suit and hat
hanging nicely how exactly took this
Washington
that's a right internet you have a new
old critic to talk about new old things
with once more finally our triumphant
champion has returned and that one with
different colors so ruined team boots
realizes they made a mistake windy
corpses the camera other new age of
entitled shamelessness begin and that
was a review must go on and even though
I may be a little emotionally
compromised by it I do think it is in
fact the greatest thing ever made the
writing be acting the absolute chemistry
from one actor to another even if
they're both usually the same actor it's
just amazing I highly recommend this
opus of openness and all its open sea
open that sickness this notice so what
are you waiting for go check out the
most amazing thing you've ever seen in
your life before the writer throws a
conscience while writing wait if I said
that that probably means he already is
he'll probably make me say it's only
okay like I just do right there get that
straight off of me puppet that's about
you have it big yeah I think this
reviews meted up to
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]